avec une vibre une fibre optique je le
précise qu'ils passent maintenant en
aériennes donc c'est quand même beaucoup
plus simple je vais passer maintenant la
parole à arnaud viala donc qui est
député de l'aveyron département rural
par excellence arnaud merci bonjour a
tous je veux juste dire au monde des
propos du président du conseil
départemental de l'oise pour lui dire
combien ce que tu fais dans ce
département me paraît devoir être saluée
par ce que à faire du ftth pour tous ça
veut dire refuser l'idée qu'il y ait une
ruralité de second rang puisque la
montée en débit ce n'est pas du haut
débit pour tout le monde c'est quelque
chose qui est dégradée en qualité et
surtout dans son évolution dans une
période où ainsi que les besoins vont
augmenter de manière absolument
exponentielle moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est d'abord partir d'un constat
par rapport par rapport à la france
cette france qui est composé de 36000
communes et je veux pas rentrer dans le
débat sur l'organisation territoriale
même fait c'est quand même une réalité
importante qui nous différencie beaucoup
aujourd'hui de nos voisins européens
occidentaux où les réformes ou
l'histoire est différente et où il n'y a
pas cette implantation locale partout
sur le territoire
je voudrais dire également qu'au cours
des dernières décennies gens de chez
nous comme jeunes de l'opposition ont
quand même par moments sacrifier la
ruralité en n'ayant pas une vision de
l'aménagement du territoire qui soit
respectueuse de cette réalité simple qui
est l'implantation des populations en
dehors de grosses métropoles urbaines
alors on a vu se succéder des d'attardés
diact des commissariat au plan mais
globalement il ya eu souvent défaut en
matière de politique d'aménagement du
territoire et de vision d'un aménagement
harmonieux permettant aux populations de
rester justement réparties sur le
territoire national et la troisième
chose qui nous frappe aujourd'hui de
pleine crise de plein fouet c'est que le
contexte budgétaire dans lequel on vit
entraîne une raréfaction des moyens
publics qui se ressemblent beaucoup plus
durement dans les zones interstitielle
que dans les zones urbaines ce constat
moi je ne reproche énormément
gouvernement en place actuellement parce
que notamment sur la baisse des
dotations des collectivités
c'est terrible ce qui est en train de se
passer et si on ne le corrige pas on
n'arrivera pas à s'en relever
la place de l'agriculteur dans ce monde
rural
l'agriculteur 1 si on veut positiver il
est propriétaire du foncier dont ils
détiennent l'espace ce qui lui donne
quand même une position importante dans
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer comme
politiques publiques
en revanche si on regarde l'autre côté
de la médaille
il est captif donc lui ne peut pas
décider de se délocaliser et doit vivre
là où il est et il souffre aujourd'hui
d'un immense mal être qui a été
largement balayée par tous les
intervenants qui se sont pressés d ici
ce matin à la tribune qui se sont
succédé à la tribune qu' liées au
contexte économique à l'incapacité à se
rémunérer correctement vos politiques
qui sont conduites etc mais qui est
aussi lié à l'évolution sociétale moi je
vis dans un milieu agricole et d'élevage
j'ai appris encore ce matin que
malheureusement un autre agriculteur pas
du tout le noeud chez moi a mis fin à
ses jours et les gens mettent fin à
leurs jours pourquoi parce que les
preuves aux problèmes économiques
s'ajoute ce décalage ce gouffre
impressionnant qui se creuse entre la
société qui tire vers le loisir la
société des 35 heures qui ne veut pas
travailler ou qu'il veut moins de
travailler et et l'agriculteur et
l'agriculteur qui lui est contraint
d'être 7 jours sur 7 sur sa ferme de se
lever tous les matins à l'aube et dalé
et d'aller travailler et ce mal être je
crois que là il ya un point sur lequel
on ne pourra pas éviter d'aller on ne
peut pas laisser se creuser ce gouffre
sur le monde rural moi ce que je voulais
dire je souscris à la fois à la notion
de bassin de vie comme réponse à toutes
ces problématiques et aussi bien sûr à
la description qu'un a très bien fait
annie je veux dire deux choses 1
on n'est pas dans un constat d'échec
et de fait on voit
les services ont diminué les commerçants
diminue et cetera mais dans le monde
rural il reste deux choses ce qui a été
décrit de notre volonté de replacer
l'agriculture au coeur d'une dune acte
d'une conception économique
c'est une activité économique ça doit
s'étendre aux territoires ruraux les
territoires ruraux sont des territoires
dans lesquels il y à un devenir
économique
ça c'est le premier point est le
deuxième point c'est que les territoires
ruraux aujourd'hui dans la démographie a
eu tendance à baisser
je pense à peu près partout s'est
aujourd'hui stabilisé ont envie d'un
essor démographique
cet essor démographique ne va pas se
faire par le seul solde naturel puisque
on veut plus enfants à la campagne qu'en
ville ou pas beaucoup plus je pense par
contre ça veut dire qu'on a une capacité
à accueillir des gens pour qu'ils
viennent vivre sur ces territoires
je pense que notre travail il est là moi
j'avance deux propositions la première
c'est que autour des nouvelles interco
autour des territoires qui se
constituent aujourd'hui il ya des
ambitions des énergies qui s'exprime de
manière très forte
les territoires savent ce qu'ils sont
savent ce qu'ils veulent on des projets
il faut les accompagner
il faut les encourager à contractualiser
avec les nouveaux immense conseils
régionaux qui ont des compétences en
matière d'économie et il faudra qu'ils
acceptent d'aller voir les petits
territoires et de contractualiser avec
eux sur cinq ans sur dix ans sur des
projets dans lesquels les agriculteurs
auront leur place et sur les grosses
infrastructures il faut que nous
ouvrions le débat sur les cpe air sur
les contrats de plan de projet état
région parce qu'on ne peut pas imaginer
qu'il ne que ces folles là soient
strictement réservées aux zones urbaines
ou aux mégalopoles urbaine donc il faut
que nous ouvrions ce débat là de manière
à ce que les territoires ruraux quand
ils font des projets comme celui que
conduit l'oise soit accompagnée à la
juste hauteur et qu'il n'y ait pas une
double peine pour le contribuable local
de la ruralité qui va payer dans ses
impôts nationaux mais qui repère ou deux
fois ou trois fois dans ses impôts
locaux
et puis il ya cette question beaucoup
plus large que j'ai évoqué à demi-mot
delà des notions nationale générale
qu'on va aborder dans notre projet pour
2010 est donc j'espère qu'elle
remplacera la ruralité laborieuse qu'on
aime et qui est la nôtre au coeur d'une
vision de la société moderne de 2017
merci beaucoup